des petites oreilles à la merci des
décibels au coeur des vidéos les plus
jeunes sont soumis aux bruits puissants
qui émane des chars des bras jack et des
groupes à pied
alors depuis quelques années nous voyons
fleurir des casques de protection et des
bouchons de réadapter mais encore
faut-il en trouver je prends beaucoup
trouvé de castries de bouchons
d'oreilles malheureusement sa mort pour
les enfants et ce serait une bonne
initiative de la mairie aux jeunes
organismes de mettre en place la ténue
quand même pas mal
les décibels d'autres ont pu profiter
d'offres promotionnelles de leur commune
n'a pas eu la chance d'avoir si le
cultiver de la menthe et élémentaire
autre nature seront en édition limitée
mais n'avait pas énormément et le
stocker
il y a donc une vraie demande
car les exposition prolongée au bruit
représente un véritable danger pour les
tympans immature pourtant de nombreux
bambins ne porte aucune protection
or avec une simple application sur un
téléphone portable
nous avons relevé 89 décibels soit 30
décibels de trop pour de jeunes enfants
bien qu'au niveau des bois jack ou comme
frappé beaucoup ça pétarade j'allume et
des bouchons d'oreille mais après en ce
qui concerne les chats qui a pas
beaucoup de bruit et femmes il est
habitué à la musique des toux fatigue
donc y'a pas de soucis mais pas effrayer
des campagnes de sensibilisation sur les
réseaux sociaux et internet ont bien
lieu de la part de l' agence régionale
de santé
pas suffisant pour certains qui
souhaiteraient une distribution gratuite
de bouchons de protection dans les
groupes à pied
on en appelle à la vigilance des parents
surtout près des caisses claires et les
bras jack les enfants ne peuvent pas
être exposés à plus de 60 décibels
embrouille donc de toutes façons c'est
un traumatisme auditif qui sera
certainement dépister avec des surdités
qui peuvent être dépistées après tout ce
sont encore des enfants on ne s'en rend
pas forcément compte de l'assaut de la
communication qui est souvent non
verbale avec les bébés et puis au fur et
à mesure des années on peut se rendre
compte qu'il ya des surdités qui qui
peuvent être décelés au moment des
apprentissages non tu ne rêves pas
banaliser des musiciens sensibiliser aux
risques auditifs comme thomas membre
d'un groupe à pied durant 14 ans ''je
allen est protégé serein il fait même un
petit somme entre deux groupes à pied